dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with dr karu jonah feher
today i will try to show you the
incredible progress
in computer graphics research through
the lens of bubbles
in computer simulations yes bubbles
indeed approximately a year ago we
covered a technique
which could be used to add bubbles to an
already existing fluid simulation
this paper appeared in 2012 and
described a super simple method
that helped us compute where bubbles
appear and disappear
over time the best part of this was that
this could be added
after the simulation has been finalized
which is an insane value proposition
if we find ourselves yearning for some
bubbles
we just add them afterwards and if we
don't like the results
we can take them out with one click
now simulations are not only about
sights
what about sounds in 2016
this paper did something that previously
seemed impossible
it took this kind of simulation data and
made sure that
now we can not only add bubbles to a
plane water simulation
but also simulate how they would sound
on the geometry side a follow-up paper
appeared
just a year later that could simulate a
handful of bubbles colliding
and sticking together then three years
later
in 2020 christopher berry's group also
proposed a method
that was capable of simulating merging
and
coalescing behavior on larger scale
simulations
so what about today's paper are we going
even larger
with hundreds of thousands or maybe even
millions of bubbles
no we are going to take just one bubble
or at most a handful and have a real
close look
at a method that is capable of
simulating these
beautiful evolving rainbow patterns
the key to this work is that it is
modeling how the thickness of the
surfaces
changes over time that makes all the
difference
let's look under the hood and observe
how much of an effect
the evolving layer thickness has on the
outputs
the red color coding represents thinner
and the blue
shows us the thicker regions this shows
us that some regions in these bubbles
are more than twice as thick as others
and there are also more extreme cases
there is
a six time difference between this and
this part
you can see how the difference in
thickness leads to waves of light
interfering with the bubble and creating
these beautiful
rainbow patterns you can't get this
without a proper
simulator like this one loving it
this variation in thicknesses is
responsible for a selection
of premium quality effects in a
simulation
beyond surface vertices interference
patterns can also be
simulated
deformation dependent rupturing of soap
themes
this incredible technique can simulate
all of these phenomena
and now our big question is okay
it simulates all of these but how well
does it do that
it is good enough to fool the human eye
but
how does it compare to the strictest
adversary of all
reality i hope you know what's coming
oh yeah hold on to your papers because
now
we will let reality be our judge and
compare the simulated results to that
that is one of the biggest challenges in
any kind of simulation research
so let's see this is a piece of real
footage
of a curved soap film surface where
these rainbow patterns get convected by
an external force field
beautiful and now let's see the
simulation
wow this has to be really close
let's see them side by side and decide
together
whoa the match in the swirly region
here is just exceptional now
note that even if the algorithm is a
hundred percent correct
this experiment cannot be a perfect
match because
not only the physics of the sophiam has
to be simulated correctly
but the forces that move the rainbow
patterns as well
we don't have this information from the
real-world footage so the authors had to
try
to reproduce these forces which is not
part of the algorithm
but a property of the environment so
i would say that this footage is as
close as one can possibly get
my goodness well done so
how much do we have to pay for this in
terms of computation time
if you ask me i would pay at the very
least double for this
and now comes the best part if you have
been holding on to your paper
so far now squeeze that paper because in
the cheaper cases
only four to seven percent extra
computation
which is outrageous
there is this more complex case with the
large deforming sphere
in this case the new technique indeed
makes a huge difference
so how much extra competition do we have
to pay for this
only 31 percent 31 percent
extra competition for this that is a
fantastic deal
you can sign me up right away as you see
the pace of progress in computer
graphics research is absolutely
incredible
and these simulations are just getting
better and better by the day
imagine what we will be able to do just
two more papers down the line
what a time to be alive this episode has
been supported
by lambda gpu cloud if you're looking
for inexpensive
cloud gpus for ai check out lambda
gpu cloud they've recently launched
quadro rtx 6000
rtx 8000 and v100 instances
and hold on to your papers because
lambda gpu cloud
can cost less than half of aws
and azure plus they are the only cloud
service with 48 gigabyte
rdx 8000 join researchers at
organizations like apple mit and caltech
in using lambda cloud instances
workstations or servers
make sure to go to lambdalabs.com papers
to sign up
for one of their amazing gpu instances
today our thanks to lambda for their
long-standing support
and for helping us make better videos
for you thanks for watching and for your
generous support
and i'll see you next time